[Music]
on this Monday night new warnings Russia
may be days away from launching a new
offensive
eastern Ukraine prepares for and dreads
what could be coming immense suffering
people are exhausted the latest Russian
Convoy and where it appears to be headed
the risk of getting re-infected with
covet it's not as simple as you got it
you'll never get it again what we know
about waiting immunity and why booster
shots matter so much the queen on her
bout with covet is horrible and pandemic
and burning desire there's no other
place like it on Earth turkmenistan's
goal to extinguish a crater known as the
gates of hell
yeah
global national with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are signs Russia's war in Ukraine
is about to enter a dangerous new phase
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
in an address to South Korea's
Parliament warned tens of thousands of
Russian troops are amassing in the
donbass region these satellite images
show a convoy of armored vehicles more
than 12 kilometers long it appears to be
heading to areas in eastern Ukraine
where Western military analysts believe
Russia will concentrate its focus in
other places such as the port city of
maryukal there has been no let up in
Russian bombardment zelenski says he
believes tens of thousands of people may
have died there and warns Russia is
using it to set an example
it is feared Russia's assault on the
East could begin within days and there's
pressure once again for the West to
provide more weapons to Ukraine before
it's too late our coverage begins
tonight with Crystal gomancing
they are heart-wrenching goodbyes
families of Ukrainian children and
vulnerable adults sending their loved
ones away in hopes that they'll be
spared people in eastern Ukraine know
what's coming
I'm from Crema tours I'm going to live
since the war started cities have been
bombed they're bombed a lot
more than 90 victims of the missile
attack on the crematorisk railway
station are still in hospital
Bayer says the station is no longer
functional evacuation routes have had to
change we have to do our best to make
all women and children leave the
territories official accounts say at
least 142 children have been killed but
that number is likely to be much higher
Russia is accused of striking a theater
being used as a shelter in maryupal in
March despite the word children being
written in large letters on the site the
city has been decimated estimates are
that twenty thousand civilians have been
killed and the fighting continues these
images reportedly show Russian tanks
being blown up
but Russian reinforcements are on their
way a tank Convoy on the road to marry
you pull Western intelligence suggests
Russia is trying to double or even
triple its presence in the south and
east these are things that we can do
Lucille marbo is a Red Cross worker on
the ground in Ukraine last week she
helped get 1 000 people to safety
immense suffering of course from from
the population
people are exhausted physically
psychologically many of those left to
hide and hope are not well enough to
leave the Red Cross is working to get
emergency supplies into Eastern cities
such as loviansk that are trying to
prepare for attacks all too aware of the
destruction and Desperation that may lie
ahead
Crystal gemancing Global News London
Canada is imposing new sanctions
targeting 33 entities in the Russian
defense sector foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie says the organizations
have provided support to the Russian
military and are complicit in what she
calls Vladimir Putin's senseless war in
Ukraine Canada has imposed sanctions on
more than 700 individuals and entities
from Russia Ukraine and Belarus
Austria's Chancellor held face-to-face
talks with Vladimir Putin today saying
he wants to exhaust all possibilities of
bringing an end to the violence Austria
is not a NATO member and does not
support cutting off supplies of Russian
gas how much influence it has is not
clear as Jackson prosco reports what
Ukraine says it really needs is more
help especially with heavy weapons first
he started Ukraine's pleas for Aid found
an audience in Seoul where president
zielinski asked South Korea's Parliament
for the weapons to win the war
what can be essential for us you have it
he told lawmakers
battered bombed out and now bracing for
the next onslaught
Ukraine sees little chance Russia will
find reason to stop its attack
fresh off a visit to Kiev and having
witnessed the horrors of bucha the
Austrian Chancellor met with Vladimir
Putin where he came to the same Grim
conclusion President Putin I have no
optimistic impression that I can report
to you from this conversation he said
the next offensive is being prepared on
a massive scale in an interview with
State tv Russia's foreign minister
Lowered Expectations even further
warning Russia will not stop its assault
to allow for peace talks there would be
no pause so long as a final agreement is
not reached and signed said Sergey
lavrov
having failed to use the pen the West
will instead turn to the sword after
Boris Johnson made a surprise trip to
Kiev Saturday the UK says it will send
more weapons the EU says it will speed
up the pace of weapons deliveries and
consider sanctions on Russian oil and
gas
the U.S says it's looking for ways to
bolster Ukrainian air defenses
immediately we want to try to get them
long-range air defense systems that we
know they know how to use Ukraine has
warned the lull in fighting is a
critical window for resupply ahead of
the next more brutal phase of the war
with diplomacy off the table the West is
still holding back from direct combat
but seems to have hardened its resolve
to give ukrainians a Fighting Chance
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
Russia is warning two of its Nordic
neighbors Finland and Sweden against
joining the NATO military Alliance
Gremlin spokesperson Dimitri peskov
claims an expansion to include the two
countries would not bring security or
stability to Europe he told reporters
the alliance remains what he calls a
tool geared towards confrontation last
week in Brussels NATO leaders and
foreign ministers discussed admitting
Sweden and Finland the times of London
is reporting possible bids for
membership could come as early as June
back in this country Ontario's top
doctor held his first briefing today in
over a month Dr Kieran Moore said it's
clear the province is in a sixth wave of
covid-19 driven by the ba2 variant he
strongly recommends people wear masks in
indoor public settings but says he will
not be making them mandatory
yes we're seeing a rise in risk and that
will be for the next probably six to
eight weeks that will have a rise in
risk of transmission
and we have the tools to mitigate it
one of those tools he says is getting
the coveted booster shot we know the
effect vaccines have on covid they
dramatically reduce the risk of serious
illness and death but they don't prevent
people from getting infected with covet
or even from getting it more than once
and as new variants emerge and
scientists learn more about waning
immunity there are reasons to be
vigilant Mike relay reports
judging by the number of people
foregoing masks at large sporting events
here Ontario seems to be over covered
however the numbers show that we're well
into the sixth wave with a recent spike
in cases adding to the estimated five to
six million ontarians who contracted
Omicron since December the difference
from earlier in the pandemic
hospitalization numbers have stayed low
still one recent statistic is drawing a
fair amount of attention for a time
reinfection was considered rare yet over
the past six months almost twelve
thousand ontarians have caught covid for
a second time the majority between the
ages of 20 and 59. I think a lot of
people were lulled into believing that
you know if they caught covid they would
be fine forever and the reality is
there's a few things working against
that for one he says the virus keeps
mutating so antibodies from one variant
won't work as well for another also only
47 percent of Canadians are triple
vaxxed and while it was originally
believe catching covid could provide
years of immunity recent Studies have
shown four to five months is more
accurate we have seen that there is a
benefit from being immunized against ba2
there's still strong protection levels
it's just that over time your protection
levels do fade from around 90 protection
against ba2 to 80 to 70 to 60 over time
on social media the reinfection numbers
have stoked the Discord over vaccines
frustrating doctors who argue explaining
immunity is about more than one
statistic the immune system is very very
complicated unfortunately it's not as
simple as you got it you'll never get it
again studies are being conducted on
reinfection but any real data will take
time to collect leaving much of Canada
in covid status quo microlyte Global
News Toronto
prime minister Justin Trudeau was in
British Columbia today promoting his
government's plan to get more electric
vehicles on Canadian roads he explained
measures included in last week's federal
budget to make EVS a more affordable
option we know that electric vehicles
are more expensive up front even if over
the long term they turn out to be
cheaper we know people need that help up
front
the five thousand dollar Federal rebate
program for EVS will be extended by
three years and expanded to include more
Vehicles there's also a pledge to spend
400 million dollars over five years to
expand the charging infrastructure for
EVS and mandatory sales targets 20
percent of all vehicles sold by 2026
must be Electric
we
had a better shot at buying a home and
starting a family than young people
today
and we cannot have a Canada
where the rising generation is shut out
of the dream of home ownership
that is federal Finance Minister
Christian Freeland giving more Canadians
a chance at buying a home was the
centerpiece of her federal budget last
week housing is the biggest Financial
challenge facing many people the Bank of
Canada is expected to raise its
Benchmark rate later this week Eric
Sorensen explains what that along with
the promises made in the budget could
mean
new houses under construction in an
Ottawa suburb if only the challenge to
meet housing needs in this country were
as simple as this looks
for starters supply chain bottlenecks
will make it very hard to reach ottawa's
goal of adding another hundred thousand
housing units over the next five years
the supply chain is continues to be
disrupted it's it's frustrating for home
builders it's frustrating for Renovators
it's frustrating for Homeowner home
buyers because of the delays we're we're
still seeing something like 10 weeks on
average in terms of delays for closing
homes but even as supplies become more
available where are the builders
immigration is swelling the need for
housing but immigration policy has not
sufficiently addressed the skilled labor
needed there is a massive shortage of
Labor across the country there hasn't
really been an attempt through our
immigration policy to try and Target uh
folks that would be of immediate value
to the construction sector then there is
the complexity of housing policy across
all levels of government it is a hot
button issue for many Canadians
Grassroots intensity around zoning
density and approval is time consuming
and creates another bottleneck where
fundamental change needs to have happen
is with Municipal governments on
speeding up the approval process and I
think the most important thing that
we've seen is that a recognition of all
three levels of government that we need
to change the way that we approach
housing the goal is an economy in which
young people are not shut out from
buying a home even ottawa's new tax-free
savings account can only help those with
enough money to save and for those who
can the savings may not keep up with
Rising house prices you can save up as
much as 40 000 but maybe it's not going
to be even enough money in four or five
years to do the down payment look the
housing market is extremely complex the
federal Minister of Housing says it will
take many tools to bring housing
affordability to more Canadians We
Believe housing Supply is one of the
solutions to to deal with with the
increase in in in prices the tax-free
savings account will also make a big
difference in that regard for first-time
home buyers Builders economists and
housing Advocates are happy to see
government tackling housing
affordability but say the crisis this
was a long time in developing and will
take a long time to fix Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
Pakistan's political upheaval coming up
the country has a new prime minister
after the last one was tossed out plus
Sri Lanka's prime minister is calling
for calm in the country's capital and
resisting calls to resign
anti-government protesters occupied the
entrance to the president's office for a
third day demanding he stepped down
they're angry over the government's
handling of the worst economic crisis in
decades it's left the country on the
cusp of bankruptcy people have been
faced with ongoing power outages and
shortages of gas food and other
Essentials
and Pakistan has a new leader after a
week of uncertainty that ended with
prime minister Imran Khan losing a
no-confidence vote his replacement is
Shabazz Sharif the brother of another
former prime minister more than 100
lawmakers from Khan's party have
resigned from Parliament to protest how
he was ousted Redmond Shannon reports on
Pakistan's latest political turmoil
Sharif Sab is declared to have been
elected as the prime minister of the
Islamic Republic of Pakistan Pakistan's
23rd prime minister Shahbaz Sharif
called for Unity after his election by
lawmakers but he was far from
magnanimous in Victory Pakistan on today
is a great day for the nation he said
because this Parliament has thrown out a
fake prime minister referring to his
ousted opponent Imran Khan who like
every Pakistani prime minister before
him failed to serve out his full
five-year term Khan fell out of favor
with Pakistan's powerful military
but not with his supporters thousands
rallying behind his call for protests
Khan the former Cricket Superstar turned
politician blames a U.S led conspiracy
for his ousters citing a diplomatic
cable he claims warned of consequences
if he remained in power a nuclear power
Pakistan vowed neutrality on the war in
Ukraine Khan visiting Vladimir Putin in
Moscow on the day of Russia's invasion
on Khan and his supporters have claimed
that you know a similar sort of warning
or Scout amount to an attempt to get rid
of the prime ministers we don't support
one political party over another
Washington denies the allegations
as does Sharif the entire process has
been tainted with the allegations of
horse trading of buying and selling of
loyalties so this is one challenge the
new government will be facing how to
legitimize itself Khan and Sharif are
members of Pakistan's Elite Sharif twice
serving as leader of Punjab Province and
its 110 million people his brother is
three-time prime minister Nawaz Sharif
the turmoil comes as Pakistan's place in
the world takes on greater significance
geographically economically and
militarily they have to perform a high
wire act to balance the relationship
with China and Russia as well because
especially with Russia Pakistan's
alleged support for the Taliban in
neighboring Afghanistan only complicates
matters as do tensions with India the
disputed Kashmir region never far from
the surface Redmond Shannon Global News
London
the queen and covid-19 ahead the
Monarch's candid remarks about how the
virus made her feel
[Music]
Todd we've heard lots of people talk
about their experience having covid-19
but not the Queen the 95 year old who
rarely reveals anything personal talked
today about her bout with coven during a
virtual visit with nurses and patients
at a London Hospital
I'm glad that you're getting better and
you and it it does leave one very tired
and exhausted doesn't it it's horrible
and pandemic
the queen expressed sympathies to a
former patient who had been seriously
ill with covid-19 and lost his father
and brother to the virus the Monarch who
turns 96 on April 21st tested positive
in February but carried on with her
duties from home Buckingham Palace said
she experienced mild cold-like symptoms
the Queen's son and heir to the throne
Prince Charles and his wife Camilla are
headed to Canada next month as part of
the Platinum Jubilee celebrations their
three-day Royal tour will include stops
in Newfoundland and Labrador the Ottawa
Gatineau region and the Northwest
Territories this will be the Prince of
Wales 19th visit to Canada
it's a pit of fire that's burned for
decades next the country eager to
extinguish this infernal attraction
it was Nirvana's biggest hit and now the
guitar Kurt Cobain played in the music
video for Smells Like Teen Spirit is up
for auction it's a blue 1969 left-handed
Fender Mustang it's expected to fetch up
to eight hundred thousand dollars the
guitar was kept by Cobain's family after
his death by suicide in 1994. his family
says a portion of the proceeds will go
to mental health charities
the darvaza gas crater is not exactly
well known at least not in the west but
it is a sight to behold it is a huge
crater that has been on fire for decades
it's off the Beaten Track in central
Turkmenistan and it's about the size of
a hockey rink Mike Armstrong explains
why it exists and why the government has
decided it's time to put a lid on it
as nicknames go the darvaza gas crater
has one that feels like it fits an open
pit burning for years locals call it the
gateway to Hell there's no other place
like it on Earth Canadian George karunis
knows the crater well an Explorer and
adventurer he's actually being inside
you totally expect the Devil Himself to
come jumping out of this crater with
horns and a pitchfork in the tail of the
whole works so I totally understand how
it got the name gateway to Hell
now it looks a lot like a volcano it's
not Coronas describes it as part natural
phenomenon and part industrial accident
there are conflicting timelines and
conflicting histories but somewhere
around 1970 a sinkhole collapsed either
naturally or because a crew was drilling
for oil and methane gas started spewing
out Soviet authorities decided the best
way to get rid of that gas was to set
the crater on fire and let the methane
Reservoir underground eventually burn
itself out that was literally decades
ago and it's burning as brightly today
as it was 10 15 20 30 40 years ago
well the burning of the methane may be
better for the environment than just
letting it Escape it's still bad so the
Turkmenistan government is hoping to
seal it up it's studying pitches from
scientists on how to do that and it has
the financial backing of an
International Development Bank there is
recognition that just hoping it runs out
isn't a great option yeah so the Gates
of Hell there are those who might miss
it mostly adventurers looking to cross
something off a bucket list I think it's
ready I think it's ready or in this
guy's case to cook a marshmallow over it
turkmenistan's former president actually
used the crater as part of a campaign in
2019 to demonstrate his Vitality people
doing donuts in the desert beside the
Gates of Hell well the country now hopes
closing those Gates sealing it off they
can put it to a better use and capture
the natural gas instead Mike Armstrong
Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is shushwap Lake near Salmon Arm
BC we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign